you know
it's not always about the visuals
sometimes all you need to tell a good
story
is someone to listen
[Music]
hey folks so after the video that i did
talking about the fact
that christopher eccleston is going to
be reprising the role of the ninth
doctor
in big finish audio stories you can
check out that video if you haven't
already
i hinted at the idea that maybe i should
do a video about how
to get into big finish and more than a
few people
wanted me to do that so let's do that
first off for full context big finish is
a company that makes
audio adventures not exclusively about
doctor who there's a number of
properties that they have access to that
they make audio adventures from
but they definitely do a lot
of doctor who related work they have
done things with tom baker peter davison
colin baker sylvester mccoy paul mcgann
the late great john hurt and david
tennant
and as i said eccleston is on his way
not to mention a whole bunch of
spin-offs for
a bunch of who-related characters
including spin-offs for
unit missy river song and
um jaco and lightfoot
if you don't know classic you don't know
what i'm talking about there but
there's a lot it's honestly kind of
intimidating it's intimidating
similar to how i think classic who is
intimidating to a lot of
fans who got in on new who so i want to
give
my advice on how to get into it
because i don't think it's that
difficult as long as you approach
it in the right way there are a couple
of
theoretical barriers to entry when it
comes to approaching being finished the
first is
you may not be familiar with the audio
drama format in general so if it's new
for you
you're gonna have to get tuned into the
frequency to it and that is not always
the easiest thing in the world don't
worry i have a recommendation as far as
that goes
there is the size of the catalog
and linked to that there's the cost of
it
these things are not especially
cheap especially if you are a completist
who is going to be looking at getting a
whole bunch of them
so that is an issue for a lot of people
as well and then because it is so big
like where do you even start
well much like when i talk about
anything doctor who related don't just
try and start at the beginning and work
your way forward
that's probably going to be a way to
bring yourself out
so the first thing i want to address is
actually the issue of
cost because there are a couple of
places where you can get
a pretty sizable selection of big finish
audio productions
without having to buy the the
actual audio drama from big finish now
i would still encourage you if you find
ones you really like to do so they're a
company that
is worth supporting and if you're not uh
that much in the money the digital
versions are cheaper than the physical
copies
but if you have a
paid account on spotify
or audible then you already have access
to big finish the first i definitely
have spotify i think all of these are
also available on audio the for
the first 50 of what is known as the
monthly range
of big finish are available so
theoretically you could actually start
at the beginning of
big finish audio again though i'm not
going to recommend
that hey it's me but right now i'm in
editing mode as opposed to presenter
mode and i realized that i completely
forgot to mention something if you go to
big finish they are frequently running
specials
or giving away certain audio dramas for
free
and if you don't want to have to scour
their entire website on a regular basis
you can sign up for their newsletters
and get alerts when those become
available so hey
one more way to get started i'm gonna
make you four recommendations
on stories to start with drawing a very
firm line under what i think the first
anybody's first one should be and then
expanding out to another three to check
out on top of that before sort of
setting you loose to
go about your own way of doing it and
all four of these i am about to bring up
are available on spotify and audible
and you can use your monthly credits on
audible to get
to get any of these so
the first one that i want to bring up
which is the one
i do think anyone not familiar with
doctor who through big finish and
especially if you are not familiar
with audio dramas as a format should
start with and that is
jubilee the reason i recommend that you
start with jubilee aside from the fact
that it is just
excellent it's just great
the main reason that i'm going to
recommend you start with it is
this audio drama was actually the basis
of the series 1 episode dalek
which is one of the best remember
christopher eccleston episodes
and i think anyone who is into doctor
who enough to want to get into big
finish has
should have seen this episode i would
hope but what this means is
you're going to get your first taste of
big finish on a story that you
kind of know not completely you don't
because first off it's a totally
different doctor
this is the sixth doctor this is called
a baker and then in addition to that
even though dalek the eccleston episode
pulls all of nearly all of its plot
elements from jubilee
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
going on at jubilee that it doesn't deal
with
so even though you know sort of the core
idea of a lot of what's going to be
going
on there's going to be all sorts of
other stuff going on around it that
is going to be new to you but because
the the main
thread running through it is something
you're already familiar with then you
don't have to worry about getting
lost by the lack of visuals
it'll make it easier for you to follow
which means that by the end of it you'll
have gotten a pretty good chance at
getting
tuned in to how to take in these audios
starting with something more familiar as
your stepping stone
the other three that i'm going to
recommend that you start with after
having done jubilee
are spare parts the fear monger
and the chimes of midnight so that's a
fifth doctor story
a seventh doctor story and an eighth
doctor story and jubilee was a sixth
doctor
all three of these other ones are great
they are terrific
examples of great stories being told
with these characters even if you don't
know these doctors particularly well
and the same applied to colin baker and
jubilee this
is a good way to get a sense of them and
get a
feel for how they are the doctor in ways
that are different from the actors in
modern who
and all three of these are great stories
spare parts might be the best one to do
second
because while it's not a direct
adaptation with world enough in time the
peter capaldi episode
that did borrow a lot of elements so
it's not as direct a translation as
jubilee to dalek was
but if you think you still are getting
your fiend under you
i would do spare parts second because
again it's gonna have enough
familiar elements to for you to ease
into it and then chimes of midnight and
the fear and monger
are more self-contained and don't have
direct equivalence going on in
the show itself but hopefully by then
you'll have gotten your feet under you
and you're doing all right now
there's a big reason why i'm
recommending these four and there's a
big reason why
this is a sampling of the primary
classic
era doctors that you will find on big
finish now they're not the only doctors
i told you all the other ones that are
on there but i do
think that big finish is more analogous
to
classic doctor who than is to modern
doctor who in a lot of ways
and if i'm being completely honest i
think for
lots of fans who came into doctor who
with the modern era
and either haven't got around to or have
had trouble
getting into classic era doctor who i
actually think
big finished stories with classic
doctors is a better way to get them
to vibe with classic hair who than
actually trying to introduce them to
classic who
is the barrier to entry with classic who
assuming that you even have a service
that allows you to watch it i use brick
box
people do ask but the the main
impediment there is
can you overlook the visuals and not
everybody can
it took me a while i've had to re-watch
classic era stories
that i initially watched about a decade
ago because
i had trouble getting over the visuals i
still do
sometimes i'm getting better at it but
that is a big hurdle especially if
you're not used to taking in
that era of sci-fi you know in terms of
its visual presentation
but that's part of the beauty of the
audios it's part of the beauty is a big
finish
it can look however you want to imagine
it to look
it's not limited by budget which as a
bonus also means that sometimes big
finish can do
wonderfully insane large-scale bizarre
ideas that like
how would you even visualize that
doesn't matter because it's not a visual
medium
but again i think it's a great way to
if you haven't already gotten your head
around the classic era doctors
to introduce them to you for you to get
what's going on with them now after you
do these first four
i would say just pick a character that
you like
and try stuff like i told you there's
lots of options
there's more doctors in and in addition
to what i mentioned there's also stuff
for the war
master there are versions of the master
exclusive to big finish who have only
appeared
in this format in this medium but people
who do listen to big finish
tend to consider to be canon there's a
lot
to explore here and much like when i
talk about classic who
i don't think you have to do any of this
in order by and large big finish does
self-contained stories
in one of two ways either if you're
getting anything off the main range
any given story that you listen to is
completely self-contained
now they are moving away from the main
range i think they're actually
discontinuing it
and they are moving much more towards
box sets
but even within those box sets unless it
is explicitly designed as
you know uh described as like part one
something like dark eyes was
then each box set is a fairly complete
story so
like for instance i have listened to and
have done reviews for
the box sets for the war master
the war doctor and missy and two out of
three of those i loved which i suppose
is the other thing
as easy as it is to praise big finish
because when big finish is good
holy cow is it good not everything's
going to be a winner
but that's true of the show too
classical modern era not everything is
great
but i think if you start with those four
you will get
a firm taste of how good it can be
how it can help you connect with doctors
that maybe you don't know all that well
up to this point
and it'll get you in a position where
you'll be comfortable just starting to
explore everything that big finish has
to offer
so again go to audible go to spotify
start with jubilee then do spare parts
and then you know do the fear-mongering
chimes of midnight whichever one you
want to do first or second there doesn't
matter but
do those four first and i think
if by the end of that if after listening
to those four
you are still like i don't think i'm
into this honestly walk away
that's fine no shade from me because
it's not for everybody i've given what i
think is the best pathway to be able to
get into it but
it may still not work for you maybe you
just don't jive with an audio format
that's okay there's no shame in that but
i think if you give those four a shot
if you are ever going to like it you
will like it after listening to those
four
thank you for listening if you like what
i do i have a patreon and that is what
is actually paying my bills
these days so any help you can lend
there is greatly appreciated even if
you're not able to liking sharing
subscribing sharing this around
share this with people who you haven't
been able to convince to get into big
finish yet
see if maybe they're willing to at least
give it a try after that
plus you know all the usual stuff
there's you know
links to social media and merch etc etc
it's all down there
whatever your thoughts are on big finish
and my suggestion
drop them down in the comments let's
talk about it but
you also don't have to do any of it
that's up to you
because end of the day you're the
council i just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]